donald trump is now afraid to even use  the word vaccine this is very  interesting in this next clip donald  trump tries to take credit for the  things he did during the pandemic and  one of the things trump loves to take  credit for is the vaccine he doesn't  actually say the word he says we did it  much faster than they said we would but  he doesn't say vaccine because his  audience is so anti-vaxx we did a hell  of a job never got credit for that more  people died under biden you saw that and  the job we did  with kovador as some people call it to  be more accurate the china virus  but we did so much in terms of  therapeutics and a word that i'm not  allowed to mention but i'm still proud  of that word he's he's not allowed to  mention it but he's proud of it because  we did it we did that  we did that in nine months and it was  supposed to take five years to 12 years  nobody else could have done it but i'm  not mentioning it in front of my people